première expédition de l'année de Omar
vivant de l'aéroport de Menton
à trois heures de route à l'ouest de
shanghain dans cette immense entrepôt
frigorifique on prépare la cargaison 100
tonnes de marre de quoi remplir à pleine
capacité un avion 747 cargo et crustacés
sont soigneusement entreposés sur 39
palettes tout doit se faire rapidement
pour s'assurer que le homard arrive
vivant de l'autre côté du Pacifique on
va dire entre 40 et 60 heures là on va
avoir 5% de taux de mortalité au maximum
ok au delà de 60 heures hors de l'eau là
le taux de mortalité commence à
s'accélérer
le crustacé provient un très grand de
majorité des viviers de la
Nouvelle-Écosse et du Nouveau-Brunswick
comme ici à Bac
Bayton exporte 80% de sa cargaison de
Omar vivant en Chine
il prévoit faire des affaires d'or avec
les festivités entourant le nouvel an
chinois qui aura lieu le 21 janvier les
exportations canadiennes de Omar vivant
à destination de la Chine on
considérablement augmenté au cours des
cinq dernières années passant de près de
260 millions de dollars en 2018 à 420
millions de dollars en 2022
le record des exportations de Omar
vivant date d'avant la pandémie
maintenant que la Chine relâche peu à
peu ces mesures sanitaires les
producteurs canadiens espèrent que les
affaires reprendront de
18h30 heure locale 747 cargo de qualité
air atterrit à l'aéroport de Menton le
homard vivant est embarqué en soute
l'avion repart dans à peine 3h
de croissance important pour la région
de la PDG de l'aéroport de montagne
a agrandi son vivier de bac B durant les
années de pandémie pour se préparer à la
reprise économique en Chine il s'attend
à doubler ses envois dans le futur pour
un 7 47 on va être ça va être plein on
aura plus
d'espaceion à ses entrepôts pour
notamment pouvoir approvisionner en même
temps deux avions cargo de homard vivant
il espère que le marché et la politique
lui souriront parce que exporter du
homard c'est aussi de la diplomatie et
les relations entre le Canada et la
Chine sont pour le moins tendu
politiciens ont un poids significatif
sur les résultats qu'on risque d'avoir
en fin d'année de marcher émergent la
Chine est désormais devenue un
incontournable pour leur marque canadien
mais demeure instable et imprévisible
raison pour laquelle des exportateurs
comme Paul Faras songe à diversifier
leur marché en Asie dans les prochaines
années avec des pays comme l'Inde le
Vietnam la Thaïlande et la Corée du Sud
ici Nicolas stanbach a du Canada à
l'aéroport de montagne